foreign
the Duke of York has been stripped of
all his honorary military roles and
Royal patronages
[Music]
you can no longer use his Royal Highness
and will no longer perform any public
duties
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
emerged his government's priority is to
grow and strengthen the economy
and help ease the cost of living for
families
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
perhaps
[Music]
he would like a marmalade sandwich
I always keep one for emergencies
so do I
I keep mine in here oh
for later
important news Buckingham Palace has
just announced that her majesty Queen
Elizabeth II has died
she was the longest reigning monarch in
British history
and the world's oldest head of state
her eldest son in Heir Charles the
former Prince of Wales is now the king
she means so much to me and she means in
fact so much to everyone
and I couldn't be prouder to be British
today and it's for me it's it's been so
much to say goodbye to her
foreign
she's dignity she reminds you of your
mum she reminds you of your grandma
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
okay Traders
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we've now got a response from The Prince
of Wales a spokesperson for him has said
that it was really disappointing to hear
about the experiences of a guest at
Buckingham Palace they go on to say
racism has no place in our society these
comments are unacceptable and it's right
that the individual concerned has
stepped down because if we have
foreign
[Music]
to protect my family
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ly want to pay tribute to all those
wonderfully kind people
who so generously give food or donations
or that most precious commodity of all
their time
to support those around them in greatest
need
[Music]